well let me tell you something about
about
like the trans stuff
there is like if you're a grown adult
and you want to chop it off or tuck it
up or do whatever
live your life exactly
but once you start talking about
kids in schools indoctrinating you know
whether you're puberty bloggers
seriously
the kids alone i got in a big fight with
my sister about this exact topic and not
that my sister's like she's my sister
my sister's actually not a liberal okay
um i don't know if my sister no she's
coming or going she's a trump fan but
she's holistic and she's like a hippie
but like i don't know i'm a hippie
conservative it happened maybe you and
her would get along great
but she's also like a ballerina she was
on uh
what's uh dancing with the stars but the
miami hispanic latino version it's
called mira cambae did i say that right
jorge miracule look who can dance
she was on that show she danced with a
hector macho camacho so the point is
she's a big dancer she went to new world
school the arts in miami so she's saying
you know uh she's enrolled my nephew
into ballet class okay
and i said
well what
i thought he was doing sports
she goes yeah but he can do karate and
basketball but also a little bit of
ballet
and i said
rory like my nephew i said do you want
to do ballet and he goes well mommy
wants me to do it and i said
pull the [ __ ] car over right here for
a second
and her and i got into a fight i was
like listen
okay i'm pretty sure we're raising a boy
here
okay and you had a ross geller moment
from friends tyler yeah he had a ross
scale around what was it taken remember
when the ross's son has the barbie doll
yeah and he wants the his son to play
with the gi joe and he's like what's
going on with the barbie doll and it
turns out that his mom who's a lesbian
they gave him barbie doll it's a moment
so listen though so i i
the way that i see that the way that i
would feel about that is like
if the kid if the little boy wanted to
do ballet oh yeah
he wants to do it no he he was like he
wanted to do what made mommy happy but i
said that's right he's a like one thing
i and
kids let the kids do the kids things
whatever
he's a boys boy like i i was like i
never played with anything other than
football's basketball baseball that was
me as a like i played high school
football high school back on college
football like the whole spiel and here's
my nephew that's like
because his dad's more of like he's a
dentist he's more of like he does hockey
but he's not like i'm coaching the kid
and then my sister is kind of throwing
this ballet stuff in there not that
there's anything wrong with it seinfeld
moment
but i'm like unless the kid is like i
love ballet right don't try to force
what mommy likes to do
onto the board she might just be trying
to expose him to a y like in other words
like some parents are like well i want
him to try art i want to see what he
likes that's totally that might be
what's going on i don't know and let me
just tell you my surprise you i never
had i talked about on the show i never
had a bobby doll this may not surprise
you at all actually i was like really a
tomboy tyler's laughing like who was
surprised by this jet i was a tomboy i
like to you know go through abandoned
houses so you were instructed to what
age
now no well you're
you're like you're an alpha female i'll
give you that but yeah but i like work
like ask me what i do in my spare time i
lift weights i work out i you know a lot
of women i'm not like a little kid i
never had like a little baby doll that i
put in a carriage and wheeled around i
wasn't into like are you like the girl
on the boys sports teams
no i didn't like teams because you know
that got in my way
no so you didn't play sports as a kid i
ran track in high school um
individual yeah let me do my own thing
yeah yeah it's like i'm not i'm i don't
like to be in a group project because i
wind up doing all the work and then i
got to carry that load i'll do it myself
that's exactly what i like being a group
exactly [ __ ] yeah
you're that guy who went out the night
before to party and then you were like
oh okay what do i owe in the group oh we
did it already adam oh all right let me
can i read it over let me actually i was
having a conversation with my best
friend's girlfriend yesterday
um and she was saying you know what i
hate more than anything because she's a
little bit younger than him so
she's like oh my my guy friends who are
like their mid-20s
like i think the most unattractive
quality is when the guys are like bros
over hoes bro dude saturdays are for the
boys it's the boys are going out
drinking she's like why she's like she's
like i would never say
girls only the girls could like me and
the girls going out girls like and i
said well you got to understand
something a lot of that is because of
sports
a lot of it is like
team like like how you said you did
individuals why guys do that but guys if
you're on a football team if you're on a
basketball team if you're winning
together if you're if you're making [ __ ]
happen together
like there's like guys have that like
and you know what you do when you all
get together and have boys night out you
cause trouble kick ass you all get into
trouble in some way some of you lose
girlfriends on nights like that or lose
teeth
loose teeth something bad happens if you
like the short clip you can catch
another one here or you can catch the
full episode right here